[Music]
okey-dokey uh Dorothy versus Alice oh
dear well I don't think orangie writing
anymore toto unless they release Star
Wars versus Star Trek Geordi I am your
father
oh so you're a black guy no where on
earth would you get an idea like that
ash thank you I choose you versus ash
[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have versus
battles or everyone at least in terms of
talking about movies granted there were
certainly a few in the old days with
monster films but for years even when
audiences demanded a crossover it almost
never happened but nowadays producers
are finally waking up and using their
copyright slicer well for the most part
and giving versus battles we always want
to see even if sometimes we wish we
didn't see them
so this nostalgia ween I'm trying to see
if I can cash in on the next big fat Oh
suck it up Pokemon go if you're
wondering where a lot it started in
recent years you can make the very real
argument that it was possibly Freddy vs.
Jason
[Music]
like many franchises they started off
from groundbreaking starts and
deteriorated to ground burying corpses
but in this case the same thing Friday
the 13th and Nightmare on Elm Street
were horror classics of the 80s that
were given so many sequels they became
literally comical I'm still shocked a
poster for Jason Takes Manhattan
doesn't look like this they got so silly
and kraut pandering that audiences
demanded the ultimate crowd pandering
after that after that Christ these
movies it was bringing them together
after years of begging they finally made
it happen and who better to take charge
of these two classic monsters than the
director of Chuckies come back with a
question mark and of course the warm-up
bad last airbender movie let's wrap up
nostalgia win with one of the biggest
horror crossovers ever good guess
Freddy vs. Jason it opens with Freddy
Krueger remembering the good old days of
the bad old days
Wood slasher that's what they called me
I remember also looking 20 years younger
but my memories weird that way the
parents burn him alive after the justice
system lets him go and he talks to the
audience about what became of it when I
was alive I might have been a little
body but after they killed me I became
something much much worse
sequels weird power glove promoting
sequels buddy brings up that somehow
people have forgotten about and he can't
exist if people aren't afraid big Dan
wasn't a problem
I've become Basic Instinct - yeah that
was the thing you didn't even know that
so he uses what's left of his power to
bring Jason back to make people remember
him as we're given this pretty classic
horror film set up is that you okay now
this is something I want you to do Stu
the younger viewers in the audience hmm
this is what they used to call a rated R
film I know you think the most extreme
films go up to pg-13 but there was a day
when movies went up to R they were
called the non pussy years which
ironically had a lot more pussy once in
a while there are films that dare to
venture into that realm but as long as
Hollywood thinks 13 is the only
demographic that exists they often
whisper this Elizabeth Banks prototype
is of course attacked by the resurrected
Jason causing her to hide
oh thank god I thought this tree was a
person I'm pretty dumb but it turns out
it's just a dream by Krueger who looks
like his mother
who convinces Jason to kill the kids on
Elm Street the children have been very
bad on Elm Street make them remember
but wait shouldn't I be on a space
station in the future and should you be
aware that you're a fictional character
in a move quiet or I'll tell the guy who
did the last witch hunter to give you
another reboot they're really doing
sorry dude we then cut to a house in
2003 where these characters are inside
playing fuck marry kill with the Three
Stooges clearly someone understands the
female teenage mind here which one had
the super bed to pay here it's a stupid
childhood this what we're doing all
night Kajal this is really stake let me
guess
she sounds like that throughout the
entire movie drop kick yo ass hurtful
dogs that keeps humping this big old
come on get real let's go shake I am so
damn close hmm and whoever's gone again
ah you know white people can we just not
white people today it's exhausting
sometimes I need a break from us maybe
some of this forest exposition will help
balance things out no one's ever gonna
live up to the fuzzy memory of your
first love Laurie you were fucking 14
yeah I know we were young but what will
and I had was real didn't mr. rill just
drop kick your ass without so much as a
goodbye hitch Christ why don't you just
pause it and show her stats like a video
game character it's much easier to take
to the natural human dialog
I mean Laura you've barely gone out
since what since my mom died or since I
realized that represents my broken
family character arc did I randomly
mention I majored in sprained gas
barrels and lighting torches I hope that
in no way plays into anything so while
they all try to figure out which
Nickelodeon TV movie they're dress for
two of them take their sexcapades
upstairs where Jason is waiting
okay I'll give this movie credit murder
by bed sandwich is not something I see
very often quick let's go out in the
rain where our clothes can get tighter
cabbie some assist the cops think it's
more than a coincidence that a murder
happened at this house on Elm Street but
they know even saying Krueger's name can
give him more power
it's got to be Freddy Krueger hey don't
even say that son of a bitch's name out
loud we just took care of our
Beetlejuice Voldemort and Candyman
problem but what'll people who're names
are bad they question Laurie at the
station while the boy hitting on her
swears revenge and whoever killed his
friend I'm gonna take him out myself
Trey
swear to God but the deep fried Sandman
comes in to make things worse okay I'm
alright well that was a natural thing to
say okay I'm alright I just thought I
calmly alert the audience of that I'm
okay I'm all right honey seems to catch
the same talking to the crowd virus not
strong enough yet well I will be soon
enough
that a fact did look pretty lame
I think links pixelated shadow would
have gotten a bigger scarier than that
well excuse me princess but Jason
finishes what he started as he cuts off
his dad's head so smoothly that it hops
off his neck when lightly touched Christ
I think Barbie's plastic head is harder
to take off
but I swear to God I was gonna take out
the killer and I never mind
talk of the murders reach a mental
institution on the acronyms attempting
to be clever news we're Lori's old
boyfriend will play by Jason Ritter
watches in horror come on turn it back
on man
I never asked for anything just turn on
the fucking TV please grunkle Stan it's
on another killing spree it's okay I got
a ton of them in my dipper joke book
will and his friend break out of the
institution though to warn Laurie and
prove they're not crazy in the most
crazy way possible one two Freddy's
coming for you cuz that's when he comes
for you in your dreams he came back back
for revenge in our nightmares I'm mark
by the way I'm a friend of wills real
sweet guy you're gonna die we'll finally
shows himself by peering on the other
side of the hallway guess mark was his
opening act but she passes out resulting
in her recovering in the nurse's office
where I guess friends can wait at some
shitty CGI I'll thank God I just dreamed
our effects were that bad so will and
Marco to see what they can figure out
about Krueger but it looks like all the
information is not available or actually
it is they just literally black it all
out that one caused any suspicion uh
excuse me I noticed everything in this
history book about World War two was
blacked out that's because it didn't
happen oh okay I totally accept that but
what about this part world sama binlong
is crossed out in cran and the World
Trade Center is put back where it was
that also did man got it oh I'm learning
a lot today Oh what about this guy in
his BP claiming they didn't say all
these famously recorded things you
didn't like that huh oh we don't have to
people just believe that one for some
reason oh he did sacrifice a lot he did
he did but we'll strangely enough has a
hard time believing all this they never
told us about Freddy because that's how
they decided to beat him they locked up
all the kids who'd make contact with him
so they wouldn't infect the others
that's crazy that's why I broke out to
warn Lori about this crazy thing I don't
believe it what am i doing again insert
early mm blurry cam filmmakers thought
would be cool whoa how come
focus on anything off a guard as
everyone partakes in a cornfield rate uh
thing man this party's awesome I
especially love the crucifying kids over
there meanwhile one of the nerdy kids
tries hitting on Laurie but kiya tells
him to buzz off you tear me down to make
yourself feel better because you really
hate yourself there's kind of pathetic
when you actually stop and think about
it assuming of course you can't think
well I don't know about you but that
drew me closer to him I really dug all
that stuff about you saying I'm pathetic
you running all the lines will finds
Laurie though and approaches her they
seem though to have a hard time figuring
out what's going on police have been
acting really weird like they know
something and where was your dad what is
going on we'll look four years ago I
thought enough with this bullshit some
little shake at and for the day Oh screw
murder man dance is all about the
dancing haven't you learned that getting
that priority straight has never been a
priority so Freddy tries to go after a
passed-out girl in her dreams
funny because being drunk stops REM
sleep but Jason killed her in the real
world before he can get to her by ice
like an intern eating the last donut at
work rude some other teens see Jason and
light him on fire but that just makes
him mad
I got nothing to say this is awesome the
teens escape just in time for will to
reveal a big secret
the reason I was sent to Weston it's
because I saw your dad kill your mom mom
dad crack Siddhant she stabbed herself
repeatedly while driving yeah I'm not
even kidding he talks about how he sees
her gets stabbed several times yet the
official cause is car accident how does
anyone believe these have asked
cover-ups
so fester hiccup and yellow feathers
would have a better cover-up than you
you can't trust him or whatever you do
don't go home with them you can't
understand you feel don't you were
confused both of us are being choked
what am I supposed to stop breathing
Laurie finds out that what will said
might and by might I mean obviously be
true as Marc starts to be messed with by
Freddie yeah I wonder what's coming no
kidding
how about you really want us to focus on
the medicine in that cabinet way to
catch us off guard he shows him his dead
brother who commits suicide and wait a
minute is that the bully from Christmas
story but now he just won't stop holy
smokes it is it is the bully from
Christmas story okay clearly the
dialogue mocking him has to be this what
are you gonna cry now come on cry baby
cry for me gotta cry haha you don't need
any effects it's your eliezer enough in
case you're wondering by the way we're
an hour into this hour-and-a-half movie
of Freddy vs. Jason notice anything
missing present Jason there's none of it
it's like playing a fighting game except
for two-thirds of the match or watching
Dawson's Creek for some reason it makes
no sense
you know what I need a break from this
bullshit I'm gonna continue to find a
more horrifying team-up
okay uh Joker versus Joker I want to
know how I got these scars I can't wait
to show you my toys oh that was easy
the ring girl versus the grudge girl
look at the actress you'll get it
devil boner vs. Santa Christ devil boner
vs. Chester to Sears one double bond
reverses devil's food cake
devil boner vs. hyper finger da I cannot
see I'm blinded by such beauty you
should keep I love you spiky chain hey
hey hey you're supposed to be fighting
the dolls are draw
[Music]
so the kids are determined to figure out
why Freddie was covered up they sneak
into a laboratory where they see all the
past survivors yeah they usually give
dead people oxygen but the human version
of droopy goes to see what's going on
and gets axed off by Jason
oh well Freddy tries to take over the
mind of one of the teens yeah that's
what Jack Black Seas in the toilet every
day so Freddy takes control of him or
those kids testicles dropped twice let
me handle this bitch as Freddy drugs
Jason up and knocks him out resulting in
him ending up in Freddy's world
tis but a scratch
we finally get a fight between these two
and honestly it is a little cool so
Freddy throwing in pinball sounds is a
little much guilt you know I'm only
doing this to you because Michael Myers
won't return my calls why won't you die
the chant every critic is when one of
these comes out it goes from red to
green because Christmas as pretty
discovers Jason is afraid of water
reducing him down to literally a crying
baby how sweet oh there's a face only on
water football
ah Freddie teases Jason so Laurie agrees
to go inside the dream to bring Freddie
to the real world so Jason can kill him
because as we all know when you sleep
really close together you've dreamed the
same dream um science just give me 15
minutes and wake me up and where's my
inception Blom she goes inside Jason's
dream where she sees Freddie torturing
him it's not my fault dish gauge is dead
on her feet that wave is so happy they
should run it at the end of Beverly
Hillbillies but now it's time to say
goodbye to Jed know his game they would
like to thank you folks for tiny buffing
in they drive to the camp for the first
Friday the 13th took place because who
knew that Crystal Lake was right next to
Elm Street
it's literally across the street as she
says it wakes up Jason only to also find
out that Freddy possessed her dad to
kill her mom oh yeah I guess that's the
big shocker in this movie you know if I
pretended that was a good twist would
you know you have nothing to offer I'm
just calling that dumb meanwhile the
teens never learned that a horror film
you keep a lantern away from gasoline
what the hell is a lantern in 2003 which
Jess gets Kia don't so mad
that does not sound like someone going
up against a killer that sounds like
someone annoyed that they lost their
Netflix login we just discovered the IT
Crowd - so they look for any weapon they
can find Erica amore mad just to wake up
while bringing Freddie with her dream
science as we finally get the big
showdown we were promised
Jesus Linda me yeah please go back to
the kids clearly we haven't seen enough
of them why don't you just call it the
OC and the COFF that kind of sounds like
Freddy vs. Jason if you get a sucker a
saying you might as well do it under
your breath
so of course Freddy chases after the
teens because why would you want to
steal fight Jason think you're so smart
huh bitch you know I use a word a lot
I really gotta learn to expand my
vocabulary it's mostly pitch based uh um
guess I'm going over here tell me
something
what is with the bug nuts you trying to
compensate for something oh I think
that's the scariest face he's made
throughout the movie that's just longing
to become a meme like Walmart as edible
panties you say or
I farted and it smells exactly how I
look do what you want with it internet
it's on me finally Jason's life it's off
bitch my movie let me get some real
fighting to be fair when they actually
do fight it is kind of fun I like how he
slams in through like a dozen windows or
fires air tanks like torpedoes even
Jason's crotch apparently is so hard it
hurts Freddy's foot oh my god what are
those made of the shops balls from Mario
3 oh no way really show throw bitch in
there
Freddy Krueger everybody the master of
nightmares hanging like a Christmas
ornament on a broken tree but our Keira
Knightley and Orlando Bloom of this
picture like the bridge on fire blowing
them up which of course is only like a
light fog to them and amount next bed
will be whose reboot is worse it's your
war sores you know it sounds cooler when
I say right
it all seems to be over until Jason
walks out holding Freddie's head
I'll give this movie this when it's
actually Freddy vs. Jason and it is fun
to see it's goofy and over-the-top but
that's why you'd expect from these
movies by now everything else though is
just kind of dull which sadly you'd also
expect from these movies by now beauty
of grown ups covering up Freddy's
existence even to the point of torturing
it isn't kids it's kind of an
interesting idea but it never really
goes anywhere it's also just dumb teens
being dumb teens and that's not what we
wanted to see we wanted to see two
monsters kick each other's asses and
what it does that it's great but when it
doesn't it turns out a long haul that
started a lot of cool crossovers but
definitely came from a rocky start and
at the very least it was rated R I'm so
sick of all these pg-13 films trying to
be our but not having the cojones to go
all the way now you hold on a minute
there sir that is rude yeah Zack Snyder
Michael Bay here where the kids pg-13 we
take credit fence to that right you two
are the reason so many our films are few
and sucky now we represent the best in
corrupting young thirteen-year-old minds
yeah it's the age where they're smart
enough to accept the best but Liz you'd
have to still accept the worst why
that's my thought too no kidding we
should talk more that's nice
no what you shouldn't you two shouldn't
do any talk wait a minute
a need for destruction the lack of
effort I'm writing not having a good
story your characters in the lease and
yet somehow always turning out a hit by
God I've discovered the ultimate
terrifying team-up who Snider and babe
the most horrifying combination of
terror ever witnessed them destroy the
minds of any child who sees their work
remember it violence isn't the answer
Ben you're Gouda drugged yeah come on
fear their ability to make the most
amazing thing suddenly seem boring and
dull hey babe I only have five
explotions for the seat of two people
talking oh well here take three
Wow ponder their lust for trying to make
the military look good but always
somehow make them look like morons
caught on Oh Maj sir
what I just think he's kind of hot now
that's good writing and flee and terror
from their never-ending use of hot women
to distract from the obvious truth oh
what's that
well it just looks like you're clearly
overcompensating for what um you really
don't know I don't know what I mean we
all discover things in our own way but
don't you think you guys might be just
might be might be what and I shouldn't
rush it you'll figure it out when you
figure it out okay
whatever you're my face oh thank you so
much oh he looked back a fast oh oh yeah
she's hot it attractive boobies right
Schneider and BAE because you'll watch
them for some reason you'll watch them
I've been a statue critic and don't say
I didn't give you anything scary
business now shall we
[Music]
coming next week can the ending ruin a
film if the rest of is good how can the
ending ruin everything but you can see
it now under vessels ad free early
access just three dollars a month to see
tons of people's videos early as well as
a bunch of other extra feature check it
out and get the early scoop now this is
really stake
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out this week we are doing the PKD
foundation this is the only organization
in the United States solely decade to
finding treatment and a cure for
polycystic kidney disease and to improve
the lives of those it affects they do
this through promoting research
education support and awareness on a
national level along with direct
services to local communities across the
country they are the largest private
funder of PKD research over the last
thirty years they have invested more
than 40 million in basic and clinical
research they do this with one simple
goal to discover and deliver treatments
and find a cure if you look at their
site and their YouTube channel you can
see all the people they helped as well
as all the lives they make better and
you too can join them in that battle so
click the link check out their great
work and see how you too can make a
difference
[Music]